you know that [ __ ] john lost like a
gajillion pounds
yeah
i did keto i was like almost 400 pounds
thank you very much we met each other at
our fattest
we both met each other at our fattest
points of our lives yeah yeah after he
started like walking all the time i was
like yeah it might be time i was like
david inspired me to like because we
were doing sent foods and i was like
very inspiring this guy man in five four
three two one como estas everybody
we have a very special guest on this
podcast today
if you don't know who the [ __ ] this is
you will know where have you been if you
have watched any send foods if you have
watched dudes behind the foods if you
watch any of tim's sketches if you
watched uh
the wine and weed podcast but we don't
talk about them because john's not on it
anymore all right so [ __ ] him all right
[ __ ] him i'm down like that yeah i don't
even i forgot his name but he's on that
show with rob durdeck i don't know you
help me but [ __ ] you yeah that's right
if you want to catch these hands
probably not
next up we got nick the ear hello
himself
yes the man from taiwan with the bombs
and it's
i mean
it is
the bomb's here
the bomb press right there baby
john how are you i'm well man thank you
for having me so john is usually always
behind the camera but if you guys don't
know on the wine and weed podcast john
actually paid a played a pretty big role
he was a host and he also shot all their
videos yeah yeah behind the camera and
it was sometimes at the same time we did
live shows i had to like run the camera
be in the show and like loki shoot the
show at the same time how the [ __ ] did
you do that how stressful by running
around a lot
and guess what he's not on the show
anymore
he's a real professional exactly you
don't need that he just got treated like
[ __ ] and that's why he's gone all right
[ __ ] journalist business
i got a
[Laughter]
all right gripe number one
all right let's yeah let's do it right
now i don't give a [ __ ] about my
connections
can we talk about that
yeah i mean what what we started now so
listen we already started
i'll tell you right now i'm a little
drunk i don't give a [ __ ] honestly this
is where david shines when he's a little
bit drunk
because he says wild stuff but it's fun
and it's always light-hearted so that's
why david's the man here's the thing man
this is what i don't like right and
you know i don't mind talking about this
because i think a lot of people don't
appreciate production as much as they
should and the reason why i say that is
because i have been on both ends i've
been a side of production i've worked as
a pa i've worked on film and i've also
been in front of the camera so i
understand how [ __ ] hard this job is
and a lot of the time when it comes to
talent they think that they know what
production does but you have no [ __ ]
idea how hard it is right they
undervalue production they don't they
don't care about the work and the time
that it takes to get it but when they
don't get the product that they want
they go why the [ __ ] is this wrong well
if you
you get what you pay for is what you get
right so i think a lot of the times when
people come into like some of these low
budget productions they expect the aria
alexa the red promoter type of footage
but they got a canon 7d type of budget
that's my camera bro yeah
we're going to talk about that later
that's my camera doug
and so
you know when when john told me that you
know he decided to leave from this
production this was what the situation
is it's like
it's not so much a representation of
people being bad it's just you don't if
you haven't walked
a mile in somebody else's shoes
specifically when it comes to this job
you don't understand how hard it is and
so when i found out that john wasn't on
that podcast this is what that situation
is it's not a reflection of who these
people are as people i don't know them
like that but from what i've seen it's a
reflection of somebody not understanding
what this job entails
john steppen there
oh wow
sending the stage well more than
anything the biggest problem was that
they were looking for someone who was
like oh i need to be here you guys are
doing me a favor but i'm just like no
i'm just i'm you know i'm just here
because i was asked to be here you know
and it became something else and i
thought i was a bigger part of it but i
guess what i wasn't so
did you feel very like underappreciated
definitely towards the end there was a
lot of times where i'm just you know um
like my suggestion wouldn't uh really
reach all the way you know i would just
be like okay i'm along for the ride you
know and then i was just kind of happy
to get whatever i got yeah because i
just started off just being a person
just to shoot it you know and then they
were testing out like the vibes and just
like where we're gonna have a guest so
let's have john sit in for one episode
to test out that guest you know
relationship and then we just it just
worked the chemistry worked i was kind
of like keeping the podcast like timing
and i'm like all right here's the
structure let's move on to the next
thing now
and then uh it's kind of evolved yeah
yeah i i'll tell you this though i did
not like the emails man
you got some emails yeah they uh like i
was just randomly like the first time
that like in my opinion that i like
actually was just like no hold on let me
stay on my ground really quick that's
right i like sent an email and then it
was just like oh no okay it's okay we
don't really need you next uh you know
it's like oh we don't need your services
anymore no just like oh
oh [ __ ] okay just like that
which kind of sucks right because it's
not and the reason why i say that sucks
and once again i don't i don't know
these people personally but there's a
certain level of decorum that you should
have especially when it comes to people
who work with you
you know because john's position in the
company in their podcast wasn't a
situation of just they you work with
them you were a part of the podcast you
had opinions you had conversations you
were in front of the camera yes so for
them to discard you as if you were just
some type of contracted worker once
again i don't know the full story right
but just how
succinct and very emotionless that was
made me feel a certain way right because
i've been on your side yeah yeah so it's
like hold on a second if we've developed
this relationship over time and you just
go hey by the way we don't need you
anymore it's like
okay
fair game if this is a job and i get
paid for it that's fine
however the way that it was done it's
not cool right and probably in their
mind they're just thinking like oh no
it's just we split um we just went
separate ways but there's a certain way
that people don't understand especially
when it comes to talent if you've never
worked on this the other side of the
camera you don't understand
what this job entails right and so when
you know at times too especially because
since you've been at the onset of that
podcast there is somewhat of an
emotional investment into it right oh
for sure yeah definitely like i said i
was just more than anything i was like
yeah i'm really happy for how long i was
here for so how long were you there for
two years wow yeah
so you started with them from the
beginning yeah like before they even
launched yeah yeah like and you were a
host for like how long it was probably
like uh probably after like the fifth
episode i was like on almost oh so
pretty much the whole time yeah yeah
yeah yeah when you work a job right
there especially when it comes to
editing in videos there's always going
to be miscommunications especially when
you're doing things over email the
nature of the business it's just how it
is right right yeah like when john and i
do notes i because i know what it's like
on production he knows my emails they're
actually very specific oh they're the
best
so he doesn't have to think i don't go
hey something's kind of wrong i go we
need to fix this this is the time stamp
this is what we do right yeah absolutely
right yeah you you funny you and tim are
like my favorite to work with in terms
of notes because like you are very
concise and know what you want and it's
very informative and then tim is just
like this is good
it's just like easy super easy imagine
if like you you've had we've been doing
this podcast and you know it's fun with
you guys right and then suddenly i just
go
hey don't come on anymore
then maybe you might come
on i'd be like that is kind of like they
were like well if you're ever in town
you know i'm like i live here
like we're a group chat people what are
you talking about
it's like
what
oh that's [ __ ] rude yo who are these
people man
hey man whenever you back in town i'm
your neighbor yeah yeah
i'm from you live in my back house man
you're my brother-in-law
we're actually kind of related now
i live in your house
that is [ __ ] kind of crazy though
yeah a little bit a little bit
[Laughter]
like yeah almost damn near 100 episodes
and then they had like a they had like a
big event for celebrating their 100
episodes and some fan messaged me was
like you were invited to this right and
i was like i don't even hear about this
until you sent this to me
they still think you live out of state
yeah
you're just you're one of their videos
just getting water out the fridge i'm
still here get the book out of here
in my face
that's not john yeah we don't know that
it kind of sucks that way you know hey
dude who needs them bro
wine and weed is a terrible combination
yes that's what i think i'm saying it
dude who are these people
i don't know who they are
it's a dumb combination just do one or
the other i mean if you're wondering
like john's not there now you guys know
yeah
exclusive
the exclusive please
hey man it's good to get that [ __ ] off
your chest yeah bro
some [ __ ] all right
nah i mean
but like i said i think it's just really
a position of just
i i think that's why even for me
before
before i even started hiring people for
editing i wanted to know what editing
takes right just because there's yes
it's there's two sides to it right
there's one side where
their editors are very underappreciated
in the camera people and there's other
people who are really good at what they
do but they lie about their job a lot
they go oh this is going to take six
days no it's not i do your job
you know and i actually ran into that
once or twice right but those are just
piece of [ __ ] people usually it's the
other way around that's what i do so
right how i get my videos
i learn how to do
hey guys
before i take you on as a client it's
gonna take you 17 years to lose this 10
pounds so we're gonna sign you for a
17-year contract
and i want those payments bi-monthly
every day on the hour and it's to me
it's me and mario you guys you guys all
mr trainer it's pretty good yeah it's a
pretty good deal
when i would hire some editing people
like i remember there was a guy and it
was to do my vlogs right and my vlogs
were super easy there wasn't any random
cuts and i could edit my vlogs honestly
and at the time it was just me talking
and then visual text and that was it and
he goes yeah these videos would take
about four days i was like don't kick my
guy there's no color correction on this
right
it's a single shot just jump cuts and
i'm telling you where the jump cuts are
it's gonna take you four days he goes
yeah it's gonna cost like a thousand for
video i'm like
come on it takes me 20 minutes to edit
this video like but i kept on running
into this and it's like and i was going
to pay somebody to do that by the way it
20-minute
like i think a videographer for for the
simple videos it's like 35 an hour it's
like average rate right and i was going
to pay 150 per video per video and it
takes 20 minutes to edit
that's crazy right and it's like why am
i even having this conversation with you
right and he was like oh i got to go you
don't have to go into after effects and
i'm like literally writing to him and
then doing the job for him yeah and i'm
like writing back to him and just
because he didn't know i was editing my
own videos yeah yeah yeah you know
taking you for a ride exactly yeah and
it was just so [ __ ] obnoxious but
yeah i think like the important thing
when it comes to work is like if you
understand what somebody else goes
through it actually allows you to have a
better relationship with them because
now you're not arguing about [ __ ]
stuff right so for insta for example
if john says like hey setup is going to
take this amount of time i know it's
going to take that amount of time
because i know what it's like to set up
right and because also too it's like
it's not like when john sets things up
i'm just go john handle it and i go my
own way you know if i can help it up and
get faster it doesn't take a lot for me
to go ahead and just help him set up
even though i'm paying for it right
because number one if we're a team i
want people to be happy having a happy
team is the best part about production
when people are unhappy you get [ __ ]
work 24 7. it seems like that's the
distinction right it's like i it seems
like a lot of times in the field like
people kind of dehumanize the people
that work behind yeah and all that [ __ ]
and it's kind of whack you see that a
lot you know did you know that [ __ ]
john lost like a gajillion pounds
yeah
i did keto i was like almost four
hundred pounds
thank you very much we met each other at
our fattest
we both met each other at our fattest
points of our lives yeah yeah after he
started like walking all the time i was
like yeah it might be time i was like
david inspired me to like i'm because we
were doing sent foods and i was like
very inspiring this guy man and bro i
remember at that time but we would be
training and he'd be like [ __ ] i gotta
go do some food i gotta eat seven
thousand calories today
you have to try everything dude imagine
having a food show and trying to diet
bro oh my gosh bro since pandemic i've
gained
20 pounds yeah definitely i've been
everybody did i was like 205 i'm like
225 right now which you know i'm still
substantially lighter than i was before
yeah but
i i i do feel the effects of gaining
that 20 pounds it's it's a little
it kind of sucks yeah you definitely
like uh less pep in my step yes like
when you're when you're bigger whether
you gain five or ten pounds when you're
in that obese because i was 300 he was
like 400.
whether you gave 5 or 10 pounds you
still feel like [ __ ] either way it all
feels the same yeah when you start
getting healthier and you make better
life choices when you gain 20 pounds you
can feel it and it's so odd yeah like
just moving stuff in here the other day
and i was just lifting heavy things i'm
like this feels a lot heavier than it
should and i'm breathing a lot heavier
than i should be and it started like
freaking me out a little bit yeah and
then i started you know looking at the
stuff that i'm eating and obviously i've
been stressed out because i'm moving
yeah all this stuff yeah like having
your health slip
feels terrible and if you if you've
never had that before it's only because
you haven't been healthier yeah it's
what i exactly yeah i had no basis you
don't know what the other side is and
what it because a lot of times too it's
like bro you see some of these fitness
people like fitness people don't do a
good job of this either right like when
they're trying to send a message about
like health and wellness and their
[ __ ] shirts off all the time and
they're all like in really good shape
like all you need to do is do this and
of course you're like yeah right [ __ ]
like of course we think that because
they don't come from it from like a like
a regular person's point of view a lot
of times and then they alienates a lot
of people but like kind of what you said
too sometimes people are trying so hard
to get their life together as far as
like their fitness stuff but they have
so many like
they have so many other things on their
plate that requires more of their
attention yeah like you moving you
having big life events a lot of times
you're not in a good place to start
dieting or or focusing on your health
you could do a little bit to kind of
maintain but i think a lot of people get
that in their head they're like oh i'm a
failure i can't get this going and a lot
of times it's just because you're not a
right place to be able to start making
those changes yeah it's really
interesting to see that especially with
like some of my clients too like
sometimes they just struggle because
like one of my clients she she has a new
job and she works nights
and i'm like bro good like it's gonna be
it could be done but it's
you have a lot more things like think
about how how much effort and cognitive
effort it took for you to like
start doing your weight loss stuff for
you were you bigger your whole life yes
yeah i i at my lightest i like wait less
than i did in freaking like middle
school oh really yeah i was obviously i
was really like 200 in middle school
really yeah well do you know why you
were so big like i mean i know it's like
a really obscure question i know why i
was big you know yeah i mean i just you
know i uh i definitely ate a lot you
know and i ate a lot of rice and i just
didn't i didn't
like think about it you know i just like
ate and that was my favorite thing to do
you know hell yeah you know why yeah
dude food doesn't yell at you yes it
doesn't call you fat yeah it just makes
you feel good
makes you happy
it puts you in the happy place of like
because food is so like nostalgic yeah
it's so connected to memory exactly
comfort you know did you ever have like
a self-esteem issues because you're
weight or were you just like i'm just
the big guy john yeah definitely i
definitely i i'd like to say that i
didn't but i definitely did um but you
know after
there was like a middle school was
definitely like me figuring and that out
a lot but by like ninth grade i was like
oh i'm just i'm the big guy everyone's
just called me big john you know i'm
like that's my identity and then um i
don't know after i started losing the
weight because like at night like i was
just like getting chest pains and i was
like is this my heart like do i need to
stop worrying about this yeah you know
and i was like i don't want i think i
should not worry about this and also you
know i'd like to [ __ ] get laid yeah
see that's and you know what here's the
thing too isn't it kind of crazy too
when i had to think about this when i
was losing weight originally was
how being fat became my identity yeah
right like absolutely if i wasn't fat i
wasn't david yeah and i couldn't
separate the two it was just always it
felt synonymous with each other yeah
it's always fat david it's never david
is david and he happens to be fat yeah
fair yeah there's the same noun yeah and
so every time i would try to lose weight
it's like oh don't need to lose weight
like i'm this is who i am i'm fat david
yeah you know i'm either funny because
i'm fat or i'm funny because of these
things right and i started to associate
this negative thing about me that you
know and that's this is how i feel about
being you know extremely overweight is
that it's some it's a very bad habit
right and i started identifying with it
it's like nah this is who i am yeah you
know i mean why am i trying to change
something that's a part of me exactly
but the things that you can't deny like
for example you had chest pains i had
heartburn every [ __ ] night right you
know every night when i would go to
sleep i would wake up in the middle of
night and then i would have acid reflux
same i thought that was normal i thought
it was normal i was like dude diarrhea
every day is normal
my nightly tums yeah normalized diarrhea
[Laughter]
solid shooters are [ __ ] racist
[Laughter]
solid [ __ ] you're covered deniers too
aren't you yeah
so
i started like making these [ __ ]
excuses you know i'm supposed to be this
big you know heartburn or whatever well
i remember just losing that first 30
pounds and then uh my uh sleep apnea
went away yeah that sleep apnea was
killing me dude like that [ __ ] literally
scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me and i
didn't know that i was holding my breath
and i i knew i had it a little bit in
college because my buddy tony
shout outs to tony vu that's the homie
he recorded me sleeping and he was like
bro i think you're dying yeah dude
that's scary yeah and he was like super
excited you stopped because he was my
dorm mate he slept in the same room he
goes you stopped breathing
at night i was like
for reals and he showed me a recording
and i went
and it was like that for 30 seconds and
then holy [ __ ] but it wasn't even then
at that point it wasn't even a huge
concern
but um
been there yeah it's kind of crazy yeah
i almost smothered myself like one time
yeah like i you know when you flip and
your face is on the pillow like i just
remember like
like dreaming like it was like my
like my my vivid dream was going like
fading and fading away and i was like
what's going on and then like i like
jolted awake and i was like if i didn't
wake up for another like three minutes i
feel like i would have like suffocated
holy [ __ ]
so for you like what was the like
continuing motivating factor for you to
continue to lose weight because you were
what 400 pounds you said yeah i mean you
because you after you lost the first
hundred you continued even further than
that oh yeah for sure yeah i i set a
goal to myself like i was just like i
just wanna i wanna go
until i'm like
healthy you know what i mean until like
i'm normal so to speak and so like i was
just like let me just see how far i can
go i would love to be under 200 for the
first time in my life you know and then
i got there um
but uh yeah it was it was great it was
it was just more of like a i think that
i had the goal to be to get to that
weight
like uh already you know what i mean so
when i was at 300 i was like okay great
you know i'm not there yet yeah um my my
mom was like you're losing weight really
fast like are you sure this is like like
you should go to get your you know get
get a checkup and i went to the doctor
and i was like i lost 100 pounds in like
five months and he's like awesome i was
like oh okay so yeah yeah i was like
okay cool i'm gonna keep going then yeah
he's like i'm gonna take your blood
pressure i'm gonna do all this stuff and
i was like all right what are some of
the like lifestyle like or i'll say this
what are some of the note uh the habits
that you guys seen that you guys changed
from when you guys were at your heaviest
to kind of where you guys lost because
both you guys lost a crazy amount of
like weight
so like i'm curious to see because i
talk about with some of my clients and i
think other people don't really talk
about this enough but the lifestyle
changes that you've had or the the
quality of life changes from when you
were heavier to when you lost about 100
or 60 pounds in your case like what are
some of the differences you guys noticed
for me the biggest thing is how i view
food
okay that's key bro yeah yeah food food
to me was just
it was a hobby it was fun right yeah and
then i started looking at food as an
energy source right it's very different
what is the purpose of food and what is
it supposed to do for you right why do
people say that you need fiber why do
people say you need x amount of vitamins
why is protein important why are fats
important yes and then when you when you
have this knowledge and you understand
food because i had you know 20 at the
time 27 years of bad habits
good habits weren't a habit for me so
which a lot of people
i think as human beings when you when
you typically just have a regular
balanced diet
it's just naturally it's this habit's
already in you you already know what to
eat i don't have that so now i have to
actually learn it yeah and so that would
develop it yeah and so now when i look
at a plate of food yeah there are times
that i just eat whatever the [ __ ] i want
but now when i feel bad when i eat the
food i know why right whether it's
excess salt excess sugar or whatever i
understand why i feel certain ways and
so the way i look at food now it just
changed a lot it goes oh
do i need to have like when i'm eating
this dish right so for example and i
just thought about this today um
jk
when i was on jk news they always took
it took us to vegas and we used to eat
at this dry age steak place uh in um
i think it was like old new york or some
[ __ ] i forgot what casino it is but
these delicious dry aged steaks right
and the first thing that i would do and
because once again we didn't you know
broke people always go big right
we ordered like a 20 ounce rib eye
right and then i would order the mac and
cheese the potato on the side and
whatever and then maybe i'll have some
broccoli
i was literally thinking about that in
the car today thinking about it and
thinking of how i would have switched
that plate up now
i would have gotten that 20 ounce stake
and i would have split it with two p
with two people
right yeah strategies right having a
plan because when i was eating that [ __ ]
i was eating it for the broke person
inside me yeah like because i like the
food bro cleaning your plate finishing
your plate yeah making sure there's
nothing left like a lot of that stuff
can those are strategies that we don't
think about but we're taught as we were
kids
and we live by that like i used to go
out to dinner with my girl all the time
and she would stop eating her food and i
would finish my plate and i eat her
plate and i kept doing that over and
over and the next thing you know slowly
gaining more weight slowly gain more
weight without me even realizing because
it's a such a habit like you talked
about like such a bad habit that we
don't realize that there's a cost to it
yeah and even yesterday when i was
eating mcdonald's i was going to go to
mcdonald's and i'm like cool i'm going
to order a filet-o-fish a big chicken
fries a coke
20-piece duggar
yeah
when i when i sat there i remember i
said to myself i was like are you going
to the electric chair tomorrow yeah yeah
yeah you know gross but but like
stopping ourselves
like do i need this much food i'm going
to have acid
bruh
literally in the car thinking what's
what are you doing
he would have gotten death rose like
that's way too much
brother i'm gonna die tomorrow but yeah
that's crazy
so i just got the 20-piece nugget and
then a drink and i was full yeah but
then i don't know why i went to wanted
to get all the stuff is because i wanted
it but at the end of the day if i want
the filleto fish i could get it tomorrow
right i don't have to eat it all right
now yeah and you probably enjoy it more
tomorrow exactly
yeah what about you
when you've going off of what you're
saying about the food choices i
definitely like i never like would pick
up something and look at the back for
the nutrition facts and stuff but that
[ __ ] is like legitimate like once you go
down that rabbit hole it's like oh my
god there's a lot of [ __ ] in this like
yeah there's like what is
maltodextrin like yeah
this you're good
how was the keto experience for you oh i
mean for me it was definitely
jarring just because you know like carbs
rise and stuff is like the best yeah um
but i did what i did like about the keto
is that you can eat until satiated and
that like and it's still fine so i'm
like a big like uh i'm not i want to eat
until i'm not hungry anymore so i
combine that with like fasting and it
just it just fit my particular lifestyle
so good so important man you were
only two of like 30 people that i know
that did keto that it worked for oh
really because i think it's very
difficult to do keto right because if
it's hard to do a just a traditional
healthy diet fair
he knows even more strict than that
because you're still getting restricted
yeah yeah
although now there's like so many like
like just uh different brands and like
in just in walmart and [ __ ] like i'm
like wow there's a keto version of this
now keto everything yeah it's pretty
hottest [ __ ] on the market right now
everybody wants to do keto because it's
like they try to sell sell it as like oh
you get to eat all the bacon and eggs
you want like i remember at the
beginning and that's what it was but
yeah at the end like i used to always
like [ __ ] on keto but at the same time
though for a lot of people it does work
like it like it's just it's a diet every
diet has its utility but exactly what it
like it comes down to is what's
something that gonna it's gonna fit your
lifestyle and that you could adhere to
for an extended period of time exactly
yeah i think keto was originally for
some it was for a specific ailment right
oh boy
like doctors were using it for people
with something i don't remember exactly
what it was but it was like tremors or
obesity
but it wasn't originally to for like the
dieting purpose it was for it was for a
specific like i want to say disease or
something like that yeah and that's what
they used it for and they found out that
it actually helped people lose weight oh
wow yeah which was kind of crazy because
i know keto is [ __ ] hard because did
you try keto i tried keto and i couldn't
do it yeah he was rough bro it uh it
made me lose my [ __ ] mind like i was
i was going to go [ __ ] insane yeah
and then i couldn't get past the uh the
migraines
oh so that's just like that's just
you're not doing your electrolytes right
oh really migraines yeah that's what
people call keto flu i never got that
[ __ ] because i i did so much research
before choosing it and they're like if
you don't want the keto flea just got to
do these three things i was like oh
really yeah most people like i have it's
crazy how many times i have like
conversations with people where they
always talk about like i have like
migraines headaches all the time and it
really is the fact that you're not
having enough electrolytes yeah and bro
she looks at me and she's like i got a
headache i got a headache and i'm like
well
we were
drinking a little bit last night known
to dehydrate you
and she still has this migraine and i
was like hey you drink some electrolytes
and she's like nah it's okay i'm just
keep drinking
[ __ ] yeah yeah i'm like damn bro
yeah
they're like athletes drink this yeah
but a lot of times it really is because
like people think it's just water but
the other side of the equation of
hydration is like electrolytes make sure
you have the minerals absolutely all
that stuff to help you you know stay
keep all that stuff because you don't
have that in the keto diet like you have
to supplement that because you're not
getting in that what are things that you
have to supplement in keto it was it's
mainly just potassium and electrolytes
and just but if you're like only eating
bacon and eggs you're gonna have a bad
time you know you need to like diversify
oh yeah you know
yeah definitely like i found my
replacement the key was i found my
replacements for like bread and rice
like i was like oh this is my go-to for
that instead what would you use for
bread so for bread they actually have
this uh
it's this thing called fat head dough
which is like it's been a while since
i've made it but it's basically a cream
it's cream cheese mozzarella you mix it
together you can like make it malleable
make it to a pizza there was like so
many weird things like truffles which is
just cheese and egg but like in the form
of like
every combination yeah
like how did it taste though you know
what i was like
if you did a side by side comparison is
it's no contest and like i've had a
bunch of keto breads and like i was i
was a big chocolate fan because like
there's just that texture you can just
make anything out of the texture what is
it is electrolytes are salt
it's it's a combination of uh minerals
and then just vitamins that you need
like vitamin a vitamin b like all that
stuff so it's it's you just need all of
it you need magnesium salt
you know all that other good [ __ ]
whatever you know
whatever [ __ ]
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy we talk about better help
a lot on this show and this month we're
discussing some of the stigmas around
mental health for example some people
think you should wait until things are
unbearable to go to therapy but that
isn't true therapy is a tool to utilize
before things get worse and it can help
you avoid those lows many people think
therapies were so-called crazy people
but therapy doesn't mean something's
wrong with you it means you recognize
that all humans have emotions and we
need to learn to control them not avoid
them
better help is so awesome better help
better help it's all about that mental
health that's the theme song i love it
so much whenever i need better help is
in my back pocket i can schedule
online therapy sessions and talk to my
counselor whenever i need him it is has
and always will be amazing if you
haven't tried better help you have to
try it give it a go you have absolutely
nothing to lose better help is a cus is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than in
person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy this podcast is sponsored by
better help a genius brain listeners get
ten percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com genius that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash genius
[Laughter]
honestly if you want to stay hydrated
just drink mountain dew red brown
let's get it dude
easy [ __ ] that's you know why i think
keto is gonna be hard for like filipino
people by the way
all your food is brown
like it's like you're allowed to talk to
you like that yeah
make sure she's right
definitely make sure the food is the
color of our mothers like that's like
it's brown it's delicious it's high in
fat high in carbs and i [ __ ] love it
what's your favorite filipino dish
oh wow
yeah it's it's blood blood porridge yeah
it's yeah it's um it when people call it
chocolate beef because it's like a
really dark color and it's like you
don't want like kids to like be like oh
that's blood but when when my parents
called it chocolate beef i was like that
sounds disgusting chocolate and beef
that sounds horrible exactly and they're
like it's blood and i was like okay now
i'm interested
that's the funny thing now you're
talking about describing it as chocolate
like meat is the way to get people to
eat it why oh yeah why like dinoguard is
my [ __ ] dude oh goodness
oh my god in a [ __ ]
pastry it's like a little you know it's
in lieu of rice you you eat it with this
pastry oh i've never had it like this
so in maui at this hotel that i used to
stay at it was like a cheap little motel
they have a [ __ ] fire ass filipino
restaurant attached to it oh hell yeah
and that restaurant serves dinawat
i ate that [ __ ] every day because a lot
of people don't even make it no it's
like it's like a in the cut kind of one
yeah for sure what about crispy patta oh
hell yeah dude i love crispy poppy there
is crazy enough there's a crispy potta
di nugu on that's what my [ __ ]
favorite yeah dude have you had a crispy
potato yeah do you like it i love it all
right i've never had it without
fire crunchy bits on top i can't wait
for a filipino friend to get married
because there's gonna be a whole [ __ ]
lechon there dude oh for sure it's so
[ __ ] good dude i don't think i've had
real like filipino food bro like besides
like lhasa that's the only other place
that i've actually been a lot of
filipino restaurants they haven't served
like kind of like chinese fast food
stuff yeah yeah and um i i there's a
really dope uh upscale i think it's
called synagogue i forgot synagogue l.a
i haven't been there i think they
they do upscale filipinos oh for sure
okay which is really great i heard it's
[ __ ] delicious but you know for me
there's certain foods that i just prefer
to have it the way that it's done and i
think like the upscale version is really
delicious but it doesn't hit the same
spot i've had that you know what i mean
they do that with korean food too yeah
with it's
delicious but it still doesn't
taste as good to me as if it was just
done homes not hardy yeah there's
something about it something missing huh
that's why loki i was impressed with
that disneyland adobo i was like yeah
this [ __ ] tastes like my mom disneyland
has adobo they had pork belly uh like a
adobo over garlic fried rice yeah it was
for the holidays though it was like a
little holiday installation thing it was
lunar new year it smelled good i was
like this looks pretty good in that
taste i was like holy [ __ ]
this is legit it was it was literally
yeah it was like somebody's mom made it
yeah and like somebody's like like like
a good version some people's mom's
making this all right
not my mom
is trash
dude i like the filipino spaghetti but
there has been variations where i get
from certain people where i'm like what
the [ __ ] is this yeah this is noodles
yeah i was like this is not filipino
spaghetti you need that tomato sauce you
need banana ketchup and sugar and that
[ __ ] is a fire banana ketchup dude
that's a game changer it has to be
banana ketchup it's not regular ketchup
it's [ __ ] banana ketchup banana sauce
yeah it's so good it's super sweet
that's what i'm saying like i i thought
when you went keto i was like how the
[ __ ] are these
definitely it was definitely what was
like your favorite food that you gave up
when you were going through keto that
you would think about all the time oh my
god honestly man like just the simple
like milk and cookie legitimately i was
like real right it's like the little
things that you crave on a diet yeah
because it sucks like that's why you go
through it we would be on the show right
and we're eating stuff i'm like hey john
get down on this food and he was like no
i was so then you had to eat all of it
sabotage
diet sabotage
you don't want this food
by
[Music]
all the carbs and everything else and he
would just [ __ ] eat the meat it was
crazy watching his willpower yeah really
good willpower man you know what i also
noticed too when i cut out um i didn't
cut out carbs but
when i was losing a majority of the
weight the only source of carbs that i
had was fruits yeah um i just like the
way it made me feel maybe [ __ ] really
good too for sure yeah but when i cut
out a majority full too the biggest
thing i recognized when i cut out cards
was my joints felt good
yeah
i felt younger yeah for sure i don't
know if that's like a scientific thing
or whatever um but when i cut out like a
lot of uh processed sugars and bats
my joints felt better so i don't know if
that's true but maybe somebody could
research totally yeah absolutely yeah
sometimes they they can kind of find
like a a relationship but but
it doesn't really say like a lot of
times people say like uh sugar is very
inflammatory but they kind of it's like
a
i don't say it's a misinformation but
it's kind of like ah it's we don't
really have proof to show that this
causes that because people say that
about red meat too right they said about
[ __ ] everything
because there's some people that like
are trying to sell a certain uh like for
instance we talk about this all the time
there's like chiropractors that
that kind of sell like medicinal
holistic approaches to dieting sometimes
and it's fine i guess you know but
there's one guy on the internet his name
is like peter berg
and he goes on and he talks a lot about
like
how you need to for you the reason why
you're not losing weight is because
you're eating too much carbs and you're
too much insulin and a lot of the
mechanisms that it uses to a normal
person would be like oh that makes sense
this is really cool but he's taking
advantage of people's knowledge of those
informations and mechanistically it's
just not correct so
sometimes if you get
the right guy with the right look that
could talk with the right like insulin
and cortisol and all these like trigger
buzzwords it could really capture an
audience of like oh this is just what it
is now like this is actually true in
reality it's like
kind of
unfounded at least do you know who the
liver king is do you guys know that oh
the dude the big jack dude that just
eats [ __ ] organ meat i'll tell you
this i've never met a person i've hated
more in my life
liver king is very entertaining but he
talks in third person all the time oh
and then also he's not man savage yeah
he he's literally he looks like he looks
like him yeah almost but just not but uh
way redder yeah
here's what i dislike about him how come
you don't talk about your liver steroids
he's
legit on every steroid possible
he is so red and veiny it looks like his
skin's about to pop yeah and he goes
this is how man ate years ago i don't
remember them injecting [ __ ] in their
ass yeah like 10 000 years ago
on my guy it's ridiculous it doesn't
even look like he's trying to hide it
but he never mentions that and then he's
like talking about his way of lifestyle
it's like listen
you don't look the way you do
because
you're eating 17 egg yolks raw beef calf
liver and then a fetus yup
but then he never clarifies he never
really clarifies because and then leaves
his audience to think wow all i gotta do
is eat a bunch of organ meat
you know take my shirt off all the time
go hiking [ __ ] attach thousand pound
sleds to my back and just walk to work
every day then i'll be jacked yeah but
in reality it's not true also
the stuff that people do when they when
when these are like the fringe health
nut people right
their [ __ ] anecdotal evidence is not
even applicable it's stupid but people
believe it they he'll he'll say some
[ __ ] like this he goes you know in the
wild uh uh bears only eat the skin of
salmon and its organs and look how
strong it is i'll tell you this [ __ ]
a bear when it's born will already rip
your [ __ ] face off it doesn't have
anything to do with the same people eat
it up
even me sometimes dude honestly
there's there's there's there's certain
guys on my youtube ads that'll pop up
one of them is named like v shred and
like the fitness community everyone
shits on him because everything he's
saying is like nonsense right
but to the normal people that aren't in
the fitness industry they're listening
to what he's saying and is like wow this
is pretty [ __ ] fire like this is sick
all i need to do is this because it's
like really good marketing but i know
that it's nonsense i know everything
he's saying is stupid but even then i'm
like
[ __ ]
he got he got something here what if i
try it like
like what if i do get jacked maybe this
is the reason why i'm not getting these
gains like dudes like
these
for some reason they always somehow
bring it back to a [ __ ] lion yeah the
safari people love that [ __ ] why what is
that because it's the evolutionary like
there's like a and and like i guess when
people arguing they use this as a it's a
nature uh fallacy to nature or something
yeah so it's like any time that it's
natural this must be good for you like
the reason why people think stevia is
better for you than like aspartame is
because they think oh stevia is from
plants but in reality aspartame is like
the safer hey ingredients poisonous
mushrooms also come from the earth
so how about you shove that in your
[ __ ] mouth there's some people on
youtube they're like you know there's
arsenic in rice this is why you should
eat rice's poison for your body download
my [ __ ] 14 day juice cleanse and it's
like yeah because it's like
this much dude it's not going to [ __ ]
kill you i think [ __ ] apples have
arsenic too yeah apples have arsenic but
it's
dose dependent yeah we're okay and by
the way japanese people live longer than
everybody to the point where it's
obnoxious and all they do is eat rice
japan has like the most amount of
centennials for real and they got
[ __ ] bombed with a radioactive bomb
yeah and they're still chilling and
they're chilling rice combated you know
what exactly
just like you know when you stick
[ __ ] uh a phone into rice it absorbs
the water guess what [ __ ] it rice does
to [ __ ] radioactive material it
absorbs it bro exactly and really good
sushi too yeah shout out to my japanese
people dude they in tara's house
they're like you know what rice will
kill you in just one japanese but i
don't think so
that's all i gotta do is what a thousand
years
a thousand year old guy with a long
[ __ ] beard and everyone would be like
no that's big rice talking dude it's a
big farm of big rice it's the political
agenda bro i'm so sick of that [ __ ] dude
leave rice alone i think rice is
perfectly fine it's all about moderation
yeah just eat rice dude i'll tell you
this most people don't get fat off of
rice yeah it's rice
with yeah pizza you know big hitters bro
like right because i think for me too
like rice always satiates me yeah it
feels [ __ ] good and there's no
problem with it you know at the end of
the day like nobody ever talks about
like portions
right they they eat like x amount of
food and they go this this food is
terrible for you well nobody told you to
eat 17 pizzas and nobody told you eat a
pound of rice with this much vegetables
so for me looking at the plate now that
i learned how to figure out what's on my
plate and how much i should eat of it
it's just completely different yeah i
used to eat like [ __ ]
12 tacos yeah it's like maybe you should
have just ate i don't know i used to eat
like like you you said like i was gonna
die tomorrow and sometimes i still do
that
like sometimes like there's times where
if i'm not being careful and i'm
watching tv and i'm a little high or
something i will eat my body weight and
ice cream hey man yesterday i was full
but i drove by a place they say i had a
pastrami burger i was like my body need
that
for real
yeah like the things that like you kind
of just you convince yourself that you
need sometimes like my girl bro she she
could have her favorite dessert in front
of her but after she's full she won't
eat anything else
yeah and she's
a normal person most people aren't like
that though that's muriel she'll eat and
she goes i'm done i'm like [ __ ]
stupid yeah there's still food there
you're done clear your plate yeah what
if tomorrow [ __ ] there's no more beef
what if tomorrow there's the pig doesn't
exist anymore
you know what that is that's [ __ ] you
not being grateful dude yeah gratitude
gratitude yeah i'm always every time
before i eat i [ __ ] get on my knees
and i bow and i pray
i go thank you
oh
hey every time let me tell you something
if you bow to your food before you eat
it it makes you look really cool and it
tastes way better bro yes thank you very
much i do with the japanese
rub it
hey man but this guy how much weight did
you lose at my peak probably like almost
200 pounds basically yeah
that's pretty nuts that's awesome are
you thinking about like diving back in
again or yeah like i'm chilling right
now no i'm definitely not chilling
yeah i'm definitely like trying to dive
back into it but i'm trying to like do
it not as crazy just because i'm
starting off at a different place right
but
i also i'm trying to get more active
because like i did not focus on doing
like any fitness whatsoever i just did
the dye and i was like this is already
hard enough
no but honestly that's a great approach
people try to do too much at once and
then they end up like most of the time
too it's like we're gonna get your most
bang for your buck is fixing your
nutrition if you just focus on that for
a little bit like you did that too david
like yeah you focus on that for a really
long time and then you started adding
physical activity yeah when you saw fit
and i think that's a really good idea
man that's how you just do it
low and slow
my lovely brain farts this podcast is
brought to you by
purple baby
if you don't know already purple has
been sponsoring this podcast for a very
long time not only because it's such a
great relationship because i really do
love my purple mattress and i'm telling
you i cannot remember a time where i
slept
just as good as i do right now and every
time i travel i miss my bed so i miss my
lady too but i actually miss my bed the
most there is nothing in this world that
feels as good as my purple mattress and
if you're thinking that you know what i
have a bed right now why would i want to
spend more money on a bed because you
don't understand that you sleep for a
huge chunk of your life and if you're
going to sleep it should be something
you look forward to every night and i
love my purple i'm not just saying that
it's literally the best bed i've ever
slept on they have the gel flex grid
which keeps you cool it's very
supportive on your shoulders neck and
back and no matter what way you sleep
it's going to be comfortable getting a
great night's sleep starts with having a
great mattress get a purple mattress go
to purple.com
brain 10 and use code brain 10 for a
limited time you can get 10 off any
order of 200 or more that's purple.com
brain10 codebrain10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more purple.com
brain10 promo code brain10
terms apply
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast
[ __ ] fun ass conversation talking
about john losing the weight and i'll
tell you man like i always like watching
people succeed in like their health
endeavors because it also kind of
motivates you right awesome what's
cooler than that yeah there's nothing
cooler because you get to see because i
feel like you know losing weight for a
lot of people who have tried multiple
times it almost seems impossible it's
[ __ ] hard man yeah and if you don't
have the right support and you don't
have the right piece it can make it
almost damn impossible do the liver can
you just eat raw foods
yeah you're doing it wrong
it doesn't matter every trend yeah
you're pretty much good to go you can't
do all the steroids and you're fine yeah
john where can they find you
i'm at john ross93 on all the platforms
subplot entertainment if you want to
hire them for any of your like video
needs whether it's sketches podcasts
whatever you want hit up subplot
entertainment they got your back they
shoot everything for me and tim [ __ ]
amazing nick you could find nick the ear
at nick the ear at nick the ear at nick
the ear still working on his po uh his
[ __ ] website always
it's gonna be up ntetraining.com but
when is this coming out uh it's gonna
come out what's going on whatever what
today yeah couple weeks yeah yeah the
website's gonna be up check it out
ntetraining.com get your fitness on get
healthy uh what other things can i say
if it's your life take control of it be
in front of the wheel if you guys want a
free fat loss guide i have a free fat
loss guide on my website at
ntetraining.com and you just download it
and it's free for you that's right i've
been using it and i've gained so much
weight it's getting too much
i gotta actually change a couple things
let's start with butter
like it's a baking recipe and julian
child yeah
all right we'll see y'all next time
peace